in california pacific gas and electric
the nation's largest utility has been
charged with involuntary manslaughter
and other crimes after shasta county
prosecutors say the company's equipment
sparked a major wildfire near reading
the fire killed four people and
destroyed hundreds of homes last year 13
major fires are burning in the state
shifting winds and cooler temperatures
over the next few days may help
firefighters a woman has been arrested
on suspicion of starting the huge fawn
fire north of reading that forced
hundreds of that of evacuations jonathan
vigliotti reports
fire crews struggled to protect
neighborhoods as high winds pushed
flames into homes scorching at least 25
structures and threatening thousands
more
devastation just a nightmare i've seen
my life gone
my
mementos of everything gone
nearly 6 000 acres have been charred
since the fire began wednesday
further south crews held back another
wildfire burning in sequoia national
park the world's largest trees some now
wrapped in flame repelling foil were
once considered naturally fire proof
thanks to their two feet thick bark but
today's mega fires fueled by climate
change are burning hotter than these
giants can withstand on their own what
more evidence do you need
of a world that's heating up our kids
are going to inherit a world
with eight degree higher temperatures
than they have today
we're on that path
governor newsom visited the sequoias
where he announced a 15 billion dollar
climate package to help fund fire
prevention and water sustainability
programs the historic move comes as more
than 9 000 crews struggle to extinguish
10 major fires across the state
and what hasn't been burned by flames
has been spoiled by smoke turning
daylight in los angeles into a neon
night
the wind has cleared out much of the
smoke here in southern california but
continues to fan the flames up north
thousands of people remain under a
mandatory evacuation for cbs saturday
morning jonathan vigliotti los angeles